everyone has a problem with time but the  day is 24 hours and we sleep six now I  know there's some out there that say  overall I need eight  but I say to sleep a little faster I  went to school I was working in  construction I was working out my five  hours a day I was taking acting classes  from 8 o'clock at night to 12 midnight I  was doing all of those things I wanted  to make sure that out of the 24 hours of  the day that I don't waste one single  hour those hours were too precious and  so they're just want to tell people  don't give me this thing I have a  difficult time with the time and I don't  have time to this none of that you have  time you make the time  [Music]